well if you thought you couldn't get any
crazier well honey you've got a big
storm coming yes everyone's favorite
cereal stalker has taken on London with
a trail of bodies that would make even
Jack the Ripper jealous in this video we
take a deep dive into season four part
two and how some of the season's biggest
reveals set up as season five so sit
back with a beer and get ready to
dissect a man who has absolutely nothing
wrong with him
[Music]
the end of part one left us with the
reveal that the Eat the Rich killer was
none other than Reese Montrose the
prospective mayor of London but as we
get further into part two we're hit with
a bombshell of a reveal the Reese
Montrose that befriended Joe is merely a
figment of his imagination a way for Joe
to separate his psycho killer Tendencies
from his everyday life in fact the book
he hides his cage key in is Dr Jackal
and Mr Hyde a story about a man with
split personalities a well-mannered
doctor and a murderous criminal but how
did Joe Manifest this split personality
in episode 8 Reese says this has been
brewing for some time starting as early
as the end of season 3 where he killed
his wife and abandoned his son it was
around this time that Joe learned about
Rhys and became obsessed just like Dawn
became obsessed with Phoebe both she and
Joe suffer from erotomania a rare mental
health condition that appears when
someone is fixated on the idea that
another person is intensely in love with
them and for the last time Kate Upton
please stop messaging me in fact in the
final episode Reese professes his love
not as sexual love but one more akin to
Brothers which would make sense since
Joe never got to see his half-brother
again after he found out he was
abandoned by his mother but why Reese
isn't it obvious
I want a friend someone who shares my
interests relates someone I can finally
tell all my secrets to not only does
Rhys provide someone with whom he can
tell his deepest darkest Secrets but
Reese represents the change for the
better a man can go through he's made
some mistakes
he's done some bad things but he changed
I'm just saying it kind of inspires me
in fact Reese's story mimics Joe's
Journey this season Rhys came from a
troubled past and threw a random Stroke
of Luck found out he's the son of a Duke
and used this opportunity to change
himself and the world hence running for
mayor Joe too has come from a troubled
past and at the end of the season he
stumbled into becoming one of the
richest men in the planet where he can
now change the world we're largely
focused on changing the world
unfortunately the real Rhys got caught
up in this whole plan when Joe
interrogates him in episode 7 Reese has
no idea who he is just like Phoebe had
no idea who Don was almost every
interaction between Joe and Rhys was
entirely in Joe's head even when Reese
was around with others now there's a
notable exception when Joel interacts
with him at Simon Sue's funeral and just
a heads up for the rest of the video
when I refer to Reese it will now be in
reference to Joe's Alter Ego unbeknownst
to us or Joe for that matter Rhys has
been busy royally messing up Joe's life
including kidnapping Marion and locking
her in one of his train our cages down
in an abandoned Subway we were led to
believe that Joe let Marion go way back
in episode 1 when he tracked her down to
an art show in London and as far as Joe
is concerned that's what happened but
Rhys drugged her coffee and was able to
get her to this safe house where she'd
witness just how obsessed Joe was with
Rhys Joe repeatedly listens to his
audiobook watches videos about him and
even collected a used gym towel Nadia
will later find a map where Joe's marked
all of Reese's favorite locations so
when Joe finally realizes Rhys is a
figment of his imagination it leads him
on this Whirlwind of Discovery where he
eventually finds Marion locked up now he
vows to let her go but he has to do it
in such a way that doesn't jeopardize
his own Freedom this leads us to The
Season's final episode of the death of
Jonathan Moore an app title since Joe
will end the season saying goodbye to
Professor Jonathan Moore his English
alias in reclaiming his real name it
begins with Joe burning a letter left to
him by Marion stating please leave me
where all be found if you remember from
season 3 a Marion is a recovering drug
addict and after finding out she would
lose custody of her daughter a fate she
says is worse than death she overdoses
hence why Joe leaves her someplace she'd
be found a park bench but as I'll get to
in a bit this was all an elaborate plan
setting up Marion's Escape Joe quotes a
famous short story by American novelist
Tobias Wolff called Bullet to the brain
that follows a hero who knows he's going
to die the protagonist in that story
also happens to be a professor who
teaches writing just like Joe Edward's
interpretation of the ending is eerily
similar to what happens to Joe say more
to die thinking of what you most love
it's a gift when Joe throws himself off
a bridge he later tells Kate that all he
could think about was her he literally
died thinking about what he loved the
most the nurse even makes a joke when he
wakes up that it's his birthday because
he died for a bit in that water this all
hearkens back to the Show's theme of
Second Chances you know my favorite
thing about love is
foreign
chances but with Marion seemingly out of
the way there's still something else
preventing Joe from his so-called second
chance that would be Kate's
multi-billionaire Father Tom Lockwood
the very man who tasked Joel with
killing the real Rhys it's very hard to
hear but the news report states that a
DNA samples were found on Reese's body
samples that could potentially link Joe
to his death Reese claims that all of
this is some sort of setup by Tom so as
long as Tom's still alive both he and
Kate can never be free so using Kate's
phone which unlocks by using the
birthday of American abstract painter
Mark rothko Joe poses as Kate wanting a
meet-up it's also kind of ironic that
this meeting takes place at an airplane
Hangar a symbol of flying away Joe
chloroforms Tom and ties him up but like
everything in his life Tom thinks he can
solve the problem with money but for Joe
this has nothing to do with money it's
about protecting the woman he loves and
this is what makes Joe and Tom similar
you and I are the same Joe we do that
has to be done throughout her whole life
Thomas protected his daughter from the
harsh reality of the world and whether
he mits it or not Joe is doing the same
in fact he basically becomes Tom at the
end of the episode a corrupt billionaire
he is the very breed of influence
peddling corruption I'm trying to
expunge so Joe is able to frame Tom's
bodyguard Hugo for the death of Tom
later taking Hugo's body and bearing it
stating that this will be the last
corpse he'll ever have to bury
this leads us to Joe's suicide earlier
on in the episode we saw him writing his
goodbye note where he can make out
phrases like simply doesn't exist the
only way better place and the people I
love in his mind his death is a
necessary means to saving Kate's life
where he states that a future with Kate
would only end up with him killing her
just like he killed his past exes he
first throws Reese over the bridge and
then himself and it's kind of ironic
this happens on a bridge a metaphor for
traveling from one end to another an old
life to a new it's only after he's
jumped as he realize that he's made a
mistake he doesn't want to die and this
according to Nadia revolves around his
fundamental flaw that he can never let
things go he fundamentally he doesn't
let things go he can't because he he's
obsessive he can't let go of Kate that
thing he loves but this also poses some
questions for season five if Joe finds
out Marion is still alive will that
Obsession compel him to seek her out can
he truly let go of the those he loves
this leaves us with the second huge
Twist of the Season that Marion has
escaped Joe's clutches in his back in
France with her daughter over the course
of part two Nadia became increasingly
suspicious of her professor Jonathan
Moore to the point that her
investigating leads her to find Marion
locked away now Nadia's downfall here is
probably that she didn't go immediately
to the police but Marion convinces her
that doing so would only make Joe flee
and the last thing either of them wants
is having to look over the shoulders for
the rest of their lives so the two of
them devise a masterful plan to convince
Joe that Marion has died step one
includes making Joe believe that Marion
has no reason to live Nadi ends up
changing the phone number of Juliet's
caregiver Beatrice in Marion's phone so
when Joe Tex her he's actually texting
Nadia she makes Joe think that Juliet's
grandmother has been given custody of
Juliet with Marion finding this out it's
enough to make her commit suicide step
two they have to replace the pain pills
meant for Marion's arm with a beta
blockers a drug that slows the heart
rate so that Joe believes she's actually
dead and finally step three Nadia
follows Joe as he disposes Marion's body
in the park and gives her a jolt of
ketamine to wake her up now Joe thinks
Marion is dead from this overdose when
in reality she Ventures back to Paris to
be with her daughter meanwhile Kate
visits Joe who was pulled out of the
water and brought back to life if he's
gonna get a second chance he's not going
to start off with a lie and vows to tell
her the truth but much to his surprise
she's already covered up the real
Reese's murder for him that DNA found on
his body turned out to be inconclusive
it's amazing what can magically happen
to DNA when you're a billionaire in her
soul she believes Joe to be a good man
and gives him a proposition we keep each
other good she will say yes to
everything he wants if he's there to
help her from losing herself if you do
this for me I'll do the same for you
this leads him to open up about who he
is and his real name Joe Goldberg but
what I found interesting is whether or
not Kate knows the truth that he killed
her father all she says on the matter
was that Tom was murdered for money
implying she believes that Hugo was the
murderer Nadia however can't let Joe
Escape knowing he's this Psychopathic
killer with the help of her friend
Edward she breaks into his flat and
searches for his Trove of souvenirs
something that would pin him as the Eat
the Rich killer but Joe is a step ahead
and devises an ingenious plan to stop
Nadia he kills Edward in broad daylight
gives Nadia the murder weapon so her
prince will be on it and is already
stashed the Eat the Rich Killers
souvenirs at Nadia's place to look as
though she found out Edward was the
Killer and killed him for it that was a
lot to get through it also works
perfectly since Edward used his parents
News company to steal Files about the
Eat the Rich killer which further
supports Edward as the Eat the Rich
killer I wonder if this also means Dawn
will be set free from jail as she was
previously framed for those murders Joe
narrates that Nadia said nothing in her
defense she knows that if she did she'd
be dead Joe is now this
multi-billionaire and he could have her
often jail if he wanted to the ending
also gives us some closure on some of
the other members of the elite group
we've followed throughout the season
Phoebe tied up all her business and
moved to Thailand to teach kids she's
finally doing something she loves and
something that will make a difference
and she's not being manipulated for her
money blessing and Sophie bought sundry
house after Adam's death rolled returned
to London after accidentally shooting a
personal friend at a farm and Connie
relapsed but the show Fast Forward
several months to New York City where
the show began way back in season one
Kate has assumed control of her father's
company and with the help of her vast
wealth a now clean shaven Joe has had
his entire history scrubbed clean just
like how Tom had many of his scandals
and bad press scrub from the web in
front of them is a journalist doing a
puff piece on the twos of philanthropic
Endeavors and it looks as though Kate's
Art Foundation is a hit with plans to
open one up in London but here are a few
important things we can take away from
this scene Joe and Kate are not married
with Jose saying that Kate has simply
been too busy for them to elope I can't
help but think that's a excuse
and there's something deeper there Joe
has also bought a struggling Bookshop
and I wouldn't be surprised if it's
Moonies from season one we also get our
first glimpse of Cynthia Tom's legal
counsel and de facto fixer I'm curious
whether they'll make her a bigger player
in season 5 considering all the back
room negotiating she was able to do
Nadia Albina the actress who plays her
advocates for more disabled
representation in film television and
theater Joe also sees Reese in the
windows reflection just like Joe
survived his date with death it looks as
though Rhys has too but what we don't
know is if Joe realizes Reese is there
or if he's embraced Rhys as a part of
him I'm inclined to believe he does know
Reese's there since his last line in the
season is him talking about how killing
has become much easier now and that he's
finally honest with himself about it as
of the writing of this video a season 5
has not been confirmed but if it's a go
expect Joe's next chapter to take place
in New York with a focus on his
relationship with Kate and Reese what
new obstacles will force Joe to protect
his love and with all that extra money
how much farther can he go now I want to
hear what you thought about the latest
season in the comments below thanks for
watching and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstory YT until next time remember
my dick's never been softer
foreign